[Music]
do you know how much water it took to
produce this hamburger two thousand
three hundred and ninety three liters
what about those chips on the side how
do the products use to grow the potatoes
affect pollinating insects and human
health from feeding and transporting
cattle to processing food the way we eat
today is not sustainable the EU wants to
make Europe's food supply chain more
viable with the new farm to fork
strategy that means protecting the
environment biodiversity farmers and
people's health Parliament wants to be
even more ambitious food security in the
European Union we want to do more of the
question of self-sufficiency and we want
to bring in the lessons learned from the
cow in nineteen breasts when it comes to
food supply farmers are at the start of
the agri-food supply chain
Emme peas want to support them along
with fisheries and fish farms during the
transition towards sustainable
agriculture unsustainable food
production is a danger to human health
but also to animal health it's in danger
to our environment we have to start
producing options in Washington
Parliament's wants to reduce dependence
on pesticides and stop the degradation
of farmland another challenge that the
EU is set on tackling through a more
modern approach to food production is
food waste 88 million tons of food is
thrown away in the EU every year
Parliament wants to cut that in half by
2030
you
you